[Music]
as you're uh disputed or reappraised bio
set you know you've worked on acute
psychiatric wards and presumably you're
making decisions about when to admit
people you know when to really you know
allow people to leave i mean what are
the terms you're using and would you
then
respond to lucy's suggestion that the
diagnostic categories
have not proven to be scientifically
absolutely valid uh i'll go for the
first picture owner i would say that
basically if your mental physical and
social my mind your mind is all your
thoughts and your feelings day-to-day
the way you think about react and behave
towards and the world behaves to you if
those are good enough
and if your body is healthy enough and
the world you live in is
safe enough and loving enough and
challenging enough in just the right
measure that's good enough to have may
you know go go go nowhere near my
doorstep let alone my ward
so we're looking about kind of an uneasy
tension between some very very difficult
things
ideal health of course would be what you
know a complete state of mental physical
and social well-being without any
evidence of infirmity that's what the
world health organization thought in
1948 now the only people i know
who have a complete state of total
perfect well adjustment and mental
physical and social is a probably an
archangel
i'll be not a person i'd like to have a
beer with
because you know i like people a little
bit screwed up i'm screwed up everyone's
screwed up
whether we're ill or not means it's
getting in the way of our living our
life
now is there a place of biology in that
lucy get real this is 2 000 and what 20
something or other covid has wiped one
of those years from my brain
but that must be a biological thing
probably glutamate in my hippocampus
but the point is that we are now getting
to the point where we can actually say
joseph ladue says this very clearly yeah
our present diagnostic systems are
complete turkey
but there's something very funky going
on between the hippocampus the central
nucleus output of the amygdala in the
presence of a threat and we can spot
that in a brain scan now
that's biology and we can identify that
as an illness i'm going to let lucy
respond in a moment i just want to bring
sarin as you're working in neuroscience
and i know you've particularly worked on
people with ptsd and also um with those
people who have autism and working on
the interceptors and so on so i mean
would you then come in on this on
neuroimaging and the kind of you know
the sort of physical properties of are
there differences observable differences
in these cases there are profound
differences and and mental illness i
mean there's a whole spectrum of how
disabling mental illness can be and i've
seen people whereas working in detroit
for five years who are so traumatized
they really couldn't live their lives
anymore and i've worked with people with
depression who have gone through phases
where they can't get out of bed and my
heart breaks for how
disabling these conditions can be and
medication can be a lifesaver medication
can get people to the point where they
can interact with the world again and
yes i am a strong believer in societal
change and social solutions but
sometimes medical interventions get you
to the point where you're able to engage
with the world again and i think it's
very dangerous to give people the
message that they're not needed in
regard to diagnostic categories no
actually the world is so interesting
there's categories are blurred in life
and research at the moment is trying to
improve the diagnostic categories all
the time i've sat on committees that
have talked about dsm there's actually a
new way of looking at diagnostic
criterion in led by the nih in america
which is looking at
symptoms uh and trying to get rid of the
categories of disorders and instead look
at types of symptoms so we can treat
symptoms and these symptoms will still
cluster in different categories which
broadly map on to the diagnostic
categories of dsm such as depression
anxiety and schizophrenia and so while
those categories are not absolute they
are useful guides in helping treat
people and science is evolving to be
more specific and i think they serve a
useful function for treatment
lucy can i bring you in on on this
question of you know the sort of types
of symptoms and you've written a lot
about language and getting away from
medical language do you want to come in
indeed so i wouldn't use words like
symptoms i wouldn't use a slight
condition i wouldn't use words like pthd
i wouldn't use words like mental illness
i wouldn't use words like psychiatric
diagnosis because these are not
diagnoses in any legitimate
understandable sense as far as i can see
so if we're going to kind of
get real as mark has urged me to do and
i like to think i've got pretty real
during my career i mean i've worked for
many many years on inpatient wards as
you have i know and outpatient settings
then actually what we're talking about
and i think this is implied in what
you're saying actually sarah is
understandable responses to life
circumstances you know a trauma reaction
is not a medical illness and in some
senses it's what our minds and bodies
are designed to do
and the healing doesn't come through
finding that interesting bit of
hippocampus mark that you just referred
to where something odds is going on at
the synaptic gap the cure is actually
helping people to process very often
through psychological means what they've
been through to help to make their world
their their and
their relationships and indeed their
feeling of safety in their bodies you
know settle down again return to what we
usually call normal those are not
medical interventions for medical
conditions those are human ways of
healing the many many forms of distress
that we're faced with including
traumatic events just do you want to
sorry so i'm going to come back to that
and and i just don't agree at all like
of course it's understandable reactions
that people have to trauma but what you
see is that everybody pretty much who
suffers a trauma has a traumatic
reaction but ten percent of those people
carry on
three months six months after the trauma
with flashbacks profound nightmares and
it's in those ten percent that it
becomes disabling and then it's much
more a biological thing that requires
some degree of intervention and i'm not
ruling off the social ones at all but if
it was just an understandable reaction
then everyone would have it and that's
not true you see this sort of
categorical split in those who have a
reaction but then deal with it and get
on those lives and those who can't
anymore can you just really quickly
clarify that i'll let mark come in just
what is the nature of the initial
traumatic reaction again is that yeah
how is that discernible within your work
um so it's really done by the time
course so just initially people will be
very locked into the trauma be thinking
about it feel like the world is an
unsafe place have flashbacks have
nightmares have sweating have hyper
reactivity of the autonomic nervous
system and actually lots of people will
have those kind of symptoms um and it's
only when they are lasting six months
beyond the trauma
and then you can really see that those
people have this pathological reaction
that hasn't gone away with time yeah i
know lucy wants to respond just like
mark respond really quickly and i'll let
you come again wow where do we begin six
months oh sorry seven months no you
haven't you should be over it by now
five months oh well let's give you
another six you know you'll still be up
until next thursday
i mean you know we've got some serious
conceptual problems here obviously
before we go any further and i return to
the idea that quote medical vacation can
be a lifesaver close quote what's life
and how does it save it
but you know we've got some real
problems here audience i'd like you to
join us now we have kind of you know the
left down in the basement we have the
body being next floor psychology bing
next floor microbiology bing next door
life lift
it's all over the place in this
supermarket of ideas i'm going to ask
you as this debate goes on so listen to
every time you hear the word medical or
biological or brain or something to do
with the vagus nerve or whatever
to try and think about what that word
means mentally physically socially and
here comes the bigger i haven't
mentioned yet spiritually my hopes and
not my god my hopes and dreams for me
and my loved ones in the future
by loved ones i mean loved ideas as well
as loved people
try if you can to come out of this
language game and try and think of
simultaneously of the medical the
biological the social and the
psychological implications of every
tricky verbal landmine we step on in the
next 30 minutes it's hard to hold lots
of ideas in your brain
the answer is in there and when society
does that bingo we are going somewhere
please start to think about it now for
the rest of this debate if you will
that's what i have to say thank you i'm
just going to move us into the kind of
second area but i'm going to bring
lucian initially to start this the
second area
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas